darüber reden wir gleich noch weiter es
geht los und ich gebe unter vladimir
selensky wird jetzt sprechen willkommen
zurück meine damen und herren liebe
freundinnen und freunde sie hätte gäste
wir fahren folgt mit unserem programm
ich denke jetzt kommen wir zu einem der
highlights dieser münchner
sicherheitskonferenz
2022 ich bin sehr erleichtert und freue
mich auch sehr wie soll ich das jetzt am
besten ausdrücken dass
entgegen einiger wahrscheinlichkeit der
präsident der ukraine doch die
entscheidung getroffen hat seinen besuch
in münchen nicht abzusagen er ist
hierher gekommen um mit uns zu sprechen
um dieses treffen abzuhalten der
präsident wird jetzt seine rede halten
und danach werden wir eine moderierte
diskussion mit christian amanpour von
cnn haben meine einzige aufgabe ist es
jetzt den präsidenten der ukraine zu
begrüßen
[Applaus]
ich denke das geht jetzt nicht mehr das
gilt der ukraine und unseren soldatinnen
und soldaten
vielen vielen dank
ich werde auf ukraine sprechen das heißt
wenn möglich
vielen dank
ich war einfach noch ganz kurz denn ich
möchte dass ich von anfang an verstanden
werde
hygiene ist
ukraine
roger moore um
ihre biografie sehnt sich nach frieden
europa wurde sehnt sich nach frieden die
welt sagt dass sie keinen krieg möchte
während durch russland sagt es möchte
nicht eingreifen
irgendjemand liegt hier das ist noch
kein aktion aber es ist auch mehr als
eine hypothese
ich habe vor ein paar tagen in bonn was
die trennlinie besuch das ist die linie
die die ukraine von denen haben
vorübergehend besetzten gebieten trend
aber in wirklichkeit ist dass die linie
die zwischen frieden und krieg steht die
grenze zwischen dem kindergarten und der
rakete die in ihn einschlägt der schule
und der herr käthe die in den schulhof
fliegt mit 30 kindern in der nähe den
kindern die diese kinder gehen nicht auf
die nato zu sie gehen auf ihre
klassenzimmer zu manche haben vielleicht
dort physikunterricht und mit ihrem
elementaren wissen von physik werden
auch diese kinder schon verstehen dass
die
aussage dass es die ukraine war die
diese gebäude unter beschuss genommen
hat mehrere weniger dumm ist andere
kinder gehen vielleicht in den
matheunterricht sie brauchen keinen
taschenrechner um ausrechnen zu können
was der unterschied ist zwischen der
gesamtanzahl der beschlüsse in den
letzten tagen und der anzahl der
erwähnung der ukraine im münchner
sicherheitsbericht andere sind
vielleicht im geschichtsunterricht und
wenn sie die krater sehen ihren
spielplätzen anstatt der normalen
schulhof dann stellen sie sich
vielleicht die frage hat die die welt
wie fehler des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
komplett vergessen diese politik der
befriedung führt doch zu nichts wie sind
wir von der frage
was
der punkt dass wir hier
das million ihr leben gegeben haben in
dünkirchen und in anderen orten jetzt
wir hier alleine gelassen werden das
sind schreckliche lektionen und ich gehe
davon aus dass wir alle die gleichen
geschichtsbücher gelesen haben dass wir
alle
uns die frage stellen wie sind wir an
diesem punkt gekommen im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert in europa
menschen sterben und krieg geführt wird
das ist eine zeit die ihr schon länger
andauert als der zweite weltkrieg wie
könnte es sein dass wir jetzt die größte
sicherheits krise seit dem ende des
zweiten weltkriegs haben wir haben ein
teil unseres territoriums verloren
tausende von menschen
150000 streitkräften schwer bewaffnet um
uns herum an unserer grenze werden nun
stehen und die antwort ist für mich
offensichtlich die
sicherheitsarchitektur der welt ist
zerbrechlich sie ist obsolet geworden
die regeln die sich die welt von nielsen
vor jahren gegeben hat funktionieren
nicht mehr entweder muss man sich an die
neue
lassen sich nicht an die neuen
bedrohungen heran wie ein
schlechter hustensaft anstatt einer
cupid impfung also
werden hier vergessen aus
unterschiedlichen gründen ob es muss
arroganz ist oder die
unverantwortlichkeit der länder auf
globaler ebene als ergebnis dessen
beginn einige länder verbrechen und
andere bleiben indifferente
haltung die sie zu komplizen macht und
es ist symbolisch wenn ich das hier sage
vor 15 jahren war es die russische
föderation die hier
bei der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
die globale sicherheit herausgefordert
haben wie hat die welt reagiert durch
befriedung was haben wir jetzt als
ergebnis gesehen die annexion der krim
und die aggression meinem land gegenüber
die vn die ursprünglich eingerichtet
wurde um frieden zu sichern kann sich
selbst nicht schützen die ihk wird hier
verletzt und von einem der vn
sicherheitsratsmitglieder und die vn
selbst ignoriert die
plattform der krim die eingerichtet
wurde um
fortschritte zu machen vor einigen
jahren hat angela merkel genau hier
gesagt werden die
puzzlestücke der welt hier wieder
zusammensetzen sie hat gesagt nur wir
gemeinsam die und das führte zu sehr
viel begeisterung ihren raum und alle
standen auf und applaudierten aber diese
begeisterung hat nicht dazu geführt dass
gemeinsam ausgehandelt wurde jetzt
spricht die welt wieder über die
bedrohung eines großen krieges was kann
man hier dennoch retten und die
sicherheitsarchitektur ist mehr oder
weniger zerstört worden es ist fast
schon zu spät darüber zu sprechen dass
sie nochmal zu reparieren es ist
allerhöchste zeit dass eine neue
entsteht die menschheit hat dies zweimal
getan und musste dafür sehr sehr hohe
preise zahlen das waren die beiden
weltkriege wir haben jetzt die
möglichkeit diesen trend wirklich auch
beim umzug ehre bevor es ein wirklicher
trend wird wir können jetzt ein neues
system aufbauen bevor es millionen von
toten geben wird auf der grundlage der
erfahrung die wir in den vergangenen
zwei weltkriegen gemacht haben ohne dass
es einen dritten geben muss
ich habe schon angesprochen in der vn
kann man nicht mehr sagen es ist nicht
mein krieg in diesem einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert die annexion der krim und
die situation in dombach ist ein schlag
ins gesicht der gesamten welt das ist
nicht nur ein krieg in der ukraine
sondern in europa deutlich 2019 2020
wieder wiederholt werden mehr jetzt
2022 zu hören es ist nicht länger eine
hypothese aber noch keine aktion warum
nun es muss bewiesen werden kann ich
einfach nur in den massenmedien
irgendwelche aussagen treffen jetzt muss
gehandelt werden die welt muss handeln
nicht die ukraine wir werden unser land
schützen mit oder ohne die unterstützung
unserer partner
wir haben
helme und die lieferung die wir sonst
bekommen haben wir begrüßen diese
unterstützung aber sie müssen verstehen
das ist keine gute gabel die wir
bekommen und um die wir gebettelt haben
das ist nicht nur eine geste und die
ukraine sollte sich nicht aus
dankbarkeit verbeugen das ist ihr
beitrag zur europäischen und
internationalen sicherheit für die seit
acht jahren die ukraine schon als schild
agiert als verlässlicher schild als
verlässliches schild das eine der
größten und schreibt hatte der welt
zurück hält eine streitkraft wie sich
jetzt auch die ukraine konzentriert und
nicht auf die grenzen der
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
haben
die im flugkörper die
unser territorium erreichen nicht die
europäischen städte wir haben den
flughafen damit bei next und licht in
frankfurt und wir sehen die
industriegebiete in unserem land die
angegriffen werden das ist bei uns und
nicht in murmansk und keines der
europäischen länder
weiß wie viele militärische
begräbnisse es gibt überall im land und
keiner der europäischen politiker weiß
was es bedeutet sich regelmäßig mit den
familien der toten streitkräfte zu
treffen nichtsdestotrotz wir werden
unser wunderbares land verteidigen wir
werden unsere grenzen verteidigen
entweder haben wir
150.000 oder eine million
soldaten soldaten wie uns entgegen
stehen die ukrainischen streitkräfte
kann man sich nicht darum wie viele es
sind oder wie viele waffen sie haben wir
müssen
viel mehr hören wie viel es von uns gibt
die ihnen gemeinsam entgegen stehen wir
müssen sich daran erinnert werden wie
plausibel eine intervention ist wir
werden
16 februar am ersten märz am 31 dezember
wann auch immer unser land verteidigen
und jeder versteht worum es hier geht
morgen ist der tag an dem wir an die
an demenz daran denken dass wir vor
jahren die entscheidung eine
entscheidung getroffen haben und viele
ihr leben dafür gelassen haben acht
jahre nach dieser entscheidung
sollte die ukraine nicht unsere
europäische orientierung immer noch
fordern müssen
niemand wartet auf uns in europa so
sollte es aber nicht sein europa sollte
doch jetzt zeigen
und sagen dass unsere bürgerinnen und
bürger der europäischen union den
beitritt zur europäischen union eine
positive einstellung gegenüber haben
wird denn diese frage vermieden verdient
es die in ukraine nicht hier direkte und
offene antworten zu bekommen und das
gleiche trifft auf die nato zu uns wird
gesagt ja zur nato steht offen aber bis
jetzt gibt es hier noch keine
möglichkeit werden nicht alle mitglieder
uns als reduzieren möchten oder keiner
uns dort sehen möchte dann seien sie
ehrlich offene türen sind gut aber was
wir brauchen sind offene antworten und
nicht jahr um jahr fragen die nicht
beantwortet werden ist nicht das recht
auf wahrheit auch teil unserer chancen
und je besser desto früher
die russische föderation sagt dass die
ukraine der nato beitreten möchte und
die grimm mit gewalt wieder ins land
einzubringen ist es gut dass es
ist gut dass das
sie haben wohl nicht artikel 5 der nato
charta aufrecht wir aufmerksam genug
gewesen denn es geht hier um
verteidigung und nicht um den angriff
die besetzten gebiete des donners und
die krim werden zurückkehren zur ukraine
aber nur über friedliche wege die
ukraine hat sich immer dem normandie
format und dem minsker verschrieben wir
möchten die hinter die territoriale
integrität und souveränität unseres
staates wir möchten eine diplomatische
lösung zu einem statt eines
militärischen konflikts haben und wir
möchten eine lösung basierend auf dem
völkerrecht also was geschieht denn
jetzt in minsk mit diesem friedlichen
prozess vor zwei jahren als die
präsidenten von frankreich der
russischen föderation die deutsche
kanzlerin und wir uns geeinigt haben da
haben wir uns auf einen umfassenden
waffenstillstand geeinigt und die
ukraine fühlt sich diesem abkommen
verpflichtet wir folgen wir
reagieren nicht auf die provokation wir
lägen vorschläge im normandy format vor
und was sehen wir im gegenzug die
angriffe beschuss unsere soldaten
sterben unsere zivilbevölkerung die
zivile infrastruktur wird zerstört in
den vergangenen zwei tagen haben wir
vieles gesehen was man symbolisch nennen
kann einen massiven angriff beschuss von
den
von der gegnerischen seite was laut
minister abkommen verboten ist die
beobachter der osze
können ihn nicht die region besuchen sie
werden bedroht sie werden
eingeschüchtert
die humanitären fragen werden nicht
beantwortet vor zwei jahren habe ich ein
gesetz verabschiedet nämlich den
uneingeschränkten zugang
internationale organisationen
humanitärer organisationen zu den
politischen gefangenen aber das ist
immer noch nicht möglich es gab zweimal
einen gefangenenaustausch und danach ist
dieser prozess zum erliegen gekommen
obwohl die ukraine die listen zur
verfügung gestellt haben es gibt
folterungen bis hin zum tod
ist in isolation gefängnis internet tun
es ist ein symbol für
menschenrechtsverletzungen geworden im
november haben die beiden neuen
grenzübergang in der ganzen korb hast
du noch nicht mal den betrieb
aufgenommen das sehen wir als
hinderung unter falschen
argumenten und die ukraine versucht
diese
politischen fragen wirklich auf die
politische tagesordnung zu setzen im
rahmen des minsker prozesses haben wir
gesetzesentwürfe vorgelegt alles wird
jedoch blockiert und niemand spricht
darüber
fordert dringend dass der
verhandlungsprozess wieder auf den weg
gebracht wird das bedeutet aber nicht
dass die suche nach frieden nur auf
diesem weg erfolgen sollte wir suchen
möglichkeiten zu finden diesen weg zu
gehen den krieg zu beenden
mit allen möglichkeiten die wir haben
paris minsk bashing barcelona wie auch
immer es ist egal wo in der welt wir ein
abkommen erreichen werden dass frieden
in der ukraine bringen wird ob es vier
länder 7 oder 100 länder sind die daran
beteiligt sind es ist egal am
wichtigsten ist dass die ukraine und
russland beteiligt sind und was wichtig
ist dass wir verstehen das nicht nur für
den frieden brauchen
brauchen frieden wir müssen den fliegen
wieder herstellen die integrität
wiederherstellen in den international
anerkannten grenzen und ich hoffe dass
niemand darüber nachdenkt dass die
ukraine ein kontinuierlicher puffer
zwischen dem westen und russland sein
sollte das wird nicht passieren niemand
will sie haben je zu lassen denn
ansonsten stellt sich die frage wer
kommt als nächstes die nato länder
müssen sich gegenseitig schützen und ich
möchte glauben dass artikel 5 der
nordatlantik vertrag effektiver sein
wird als das budapester memory
die tatsache
dass wir von der drittgrößten
atommacht
sicherheitsgarantien bekommen wir haben
länger sie haben diese wahl die
macht haben wir haben am teile unseres
territoriums verloren was gebiete sind
die größer sind als die schweiz die
niederlande oder belgien millionen von
bürgerinnen und bürger haben wir
verloren
dies verloren aber wir haben noch etwas
wir haben das recht zu verlangen dass
sichergestellt wird dass wir
sicherheitsgarantien bekommt seit 2014
hat die ukraine drei mal versucht
konsultationen auf den weg zu bringen
dass wir mit den ländern zusammen
sprechen können die das budapester
abkommen als garant ohren unterzeichnet
haben und wir machen das jetzt zum
vierten mal als präsident mache ich es
zum ersten mal aber sowohl die ukraine
als auch ich werden die es jetzt zum
letzten mal tun wir
die außenminister auf dieses abzuhalten
und als ergebnis nun
exklusiv wenn es danach keine friedens
garantie gibt sicherheitsgarantie gibt
dann gehen wir davon aus dass das
budapester memorandum nicht funktioniert
und alles was 1994 beschlossen wurde
dadurch in frage gestellt in den
kommenden wochen schlage ich vor ein
gipfel der mitgliedsländer der sicher
des sicherheitsrates abzuhalten mit in
europa deutschland und der türkei noch
mit drei um neue effektive
sicherheitsgarantien für die ukraine auf
den weg zu bringen garantie die wir
brauchen bevor wir
mitglieder im
verteidigungsrat
werden und in diesem sieg bieten
sicherheitsvakuum uns befinden was
können wir jetzt noch tun
wir können die unterstützung der ukraine
weiter führen die unterstützung der
verteidigungsfähigkeiten die
unterstützung so wie sie die
kandidatenländer auch bekommen und man
kann eine
für die ukrainische mitgliedschaft im
bündnis zur verfügung stellen wir müssen
stabilität
erreichen wir müssen
restaurations fonds auf den weg bringen
neue waffen zur verfügung gestellten für
die streitkräfte die ja eigentlich ganz
europa schützen wir brauchen ein paket
an sanktionen um die aggression 1 ohne
die energie integration der ukraine in
die europäische union und das alles in
zeiten in denen energie auch als waffe
genutzt wird das sind antworten die
möglich sind und was bekommen wir im
gegenzug ihr schweigen und
dieses schweigen so lange es anhält wird
es im osten der ukraine kein schweigen
geben im osten europas und dadurch in
der gesamten welt und ich hoffe dass die
welt dass europa die es verstehen wird
meine damen und herren
bei den ländern die die ukraine mit
ihren erklärungen mit ihren worten und
ihren spezifischen unterstützung
unterstützen die die auf unserer seite
stehen auf der seite der wahrheit auf
der seite des völkerrechts und ich
möchte meine freunde hier nicht
namentlich nennen ich möchte nicht dass
einige länder
sich zu schämen aber es sind ihre dinge
es sind ihre länder ihre entscheidungen
ihr karma ihr gewissen mit dem sie leben
müssen ich weiß nicht wie sie diese
entscheidung das ist handeln den beiden
menschen erklären die heute getötet
wurden den drei verletzten ukrainischen
soldaten und drei mädchen 6 10 und ein
jahr alt die jetzt nicht länger einen
vater haben um sechs uhr morgens
osteuropäischer zeit als
ukrainische soldat getötet wurde
von einem beschuss der eigentlich das
müze abkommen verboten
ich weiß nicht was ihm durch den kopf
gehen in diesen letzten sekunden seines
lebens
ich weiß nicht was hier auf der
tagesordnung stehen muss um diesen krieg
im osten zu beenden aber was er
sicherlich wusste war die antwort auf
die frage die ich ganz am anfang
gestellt habe
ganz genau wer hier lügt
herzliches beileid
ruhe in frieden
und all die die in diesen jahren des
krieges im osten unseres landes ums
leben gekommen sind
[Applaus]
bekanntlich hatte seine
leidenschaftliche rede gehalten und ohne
arbeit du hast aber zunächst unbedingt
sie fragen ich weiß nicht wie viele
personen in dem frauen erwartet haben
wir uns einfach scheidung land sowie
herzukommen was war so wichtig für sie
dass sie hergekommen sind oder was
wissen sie über die absichten von
vladimir putin geführt dass die usa oder
andere vielleicht nicht wissen sie
denken dass wladimir putin die
entscheidung getroffen hat in irland
einzuwandern
danke für
die einladung
informationen
selbst kommen und er hat mir der
präsident des landes und
nicht das amt heute hinterm rücken
abkommen treffen und ich denke dass das
der fall ist
heute mit den staatschefs wichtiger
länder und habe noch einige treffen fand
ich würde heute gerne fragen stellen und
antworten erhalten und mehrere verfahren
wie resident unser land ist wir sind
nicht panisch spiel sind sehr konsistent
wir reagieren nicht auf jedwede
provokation wir haben unsere eigene
impfung dafür entwickelt werde man so
will das ist nicht so gut wie die puppe
die impfung aber
wir kennen die lage ja schon länger also
unser impfstoff ist schon sehr sehr alt
das heißt wir wissen wie wir auf direkt
situation reagieren müssen und wir
wissen ich habe direktion direktem
auszusehen hat und wir verstehen
wo die militärischen verbände sich
aufhalten wir sind dahinter steckt und
so weiter und wir wissen auch was
passiert
wenn geschossen wird und was das für die
zivilisten bedeutet die zivilbevölkerung
und dass das ziel ist uns zu provozieren
zu einer antwort hinreißen zu lassen auf
eine eskalation auf unserer seite zu
beginnen wir wissen dass das dahinter
steckt dass wir dazu gezwungen werden
sollen auf das feuer zu reagieren es ist
aber auch wichtig dass wir hier alle auf
dem gleichen stand sind hier
den partner informationen mit uns dafür
sind wir sehr dankbar auch für die
zusammenarbeit zwischen den
nachrichtendiensten
aber wir kennen diese
entspannungszustand jetzt schon seit
jahren und wir denken nicht dass es
jetzt zeit ist panisch zu werden also
die risse und das risiko ist sehr hoch
das stimmt wir haben ein 40.000
soldatinnen und soldaten an unserer
grenze ja das risiko ist also hoch
wenn wir reagieren würden darauf dann
wäre das risiko noch größer also wenn
wir uns eine reaktion auf eine
provokation hinreißen lassen auf der
anderen seite die russische föderation
und wenn wir da als über russland
sprechen
dann sind das die mensch
also das russische volk und das
russische volk die ist nicht in der lage
oder möchte nicht in den krieg ziehen
gegen die ukraine aber
in den ecksätzen gebieten erleben wir
viel provokation
das sehen wir
hier sehen dass durch die massenmedien
es gibt unterschiedliche provokation
maßnahmen provokative informationen die
verteilt werden aber wir müssen ruhig
bleiben stabil bleiben
das heißt also die
location als antworten unseren
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern auf
phoenix müssen wir uns jetzt leider
verabschieden wer aber